SPEAKER 1: OK, everybody.
So our next session
is security identity.
To moderate this session
we have Michael Coates
from Shape Security.
MICHAEL COATES: Well, I'm
really excited to be here.
We've got a great
panel lined up.
I think we're going to have some
very interesting conversations.
As everyone probably knows,
security is not easy.
Not that anything else we
talked about today was easy,
but there are certainly
some loaded topics.
And I'm really excited for
some good feedback and comments
from the audience.
As a reminder, so
we can highlight you
on the Livestream, do stand
up when you ask a question
so we'll get all of you in that.
Briefly introducing everyone
starting over here to my right,
we've got Mark
Nottingham at Akamai.
He comes to us from Australia.
WG chair for HTTP/2, tons of
work on protocols and formats,
some stuff on RSS,
atom, web services,
all sorts of good stuff.
No?
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
No web services.
MICHAEL COATES:
Not web services.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: I
never did web services.
MICHAEL COATES:
Nothing there, OK.
K [INAUDIBLE] encryption.
[INAUDIBLE], and also working
on a HTTPS [INAUDIBLE]
and SecureDrop,
among other things.
Chris [INAUDIBLE] Cisco.
[INAUDIBLE] Foundation,
worked with identity
in the [INAUDIBLE].
In Tokyo, co-chair of the web
and mobile interest group,
and lots of information
on the mobile front.
And Mike coming from
Google based in Munich.
Lots of work with the
Chrome privacy team.
Items like HSTS, mixed content.
Maybe not HSTS, but
we'll talk about that.
It's on my agenda, certainly.
Mixed content and
content security policy.
So we'll kick things off with
a brief presentation from Yan.
YAN ZHU: OK, so I think my
name's pronounced "yawn",
but it's OK if you
guys mess it up.
So welcome to the security
and identity session.
Yeah, identities are fluid.
So I hope to convince
you that this
is one of the more
interesting sessions,
but my perspective is
honestly very biased
because security is so broad.
So I will definitely not
cover the whole scope
of what you can ask
during this session.
So how many of you have
ever felt insecure,
because you're insecure
about your job, or your love
life, or finances?
So some of us haven't
felt any of those things,
but we still use Quora.
And when you use
a site like Quora
that has 10 million-ish
monthly active users,
you are sending your password
and username over plain HTTP.
And I checked this
like a month ago.
Not just serving the
login form over HTTP,
they're actually sending a
post request over plain HTTP.
And this is 2014, and
why are we not angry?
Well, SSL is hard, but
let's try to make it easier.
And that's one of the
themes we'll talk about.
So how many people
recognize this slide?
How many people have
heard of Edward Snowden?
So Edward Snowden
sort of put HTTP--
made HTTP look much
worse than it did before,
because we saw NSA slides
that say, why are we
interested in HTTP?
Because HTTP allows the NSA
to do mass surveillance,
according to these sides.
And so what previously we
would say, if you use HTTP,
someone at your coffee shop
can sniff your traffic,
and read your passwords,
and that's bad.
But now we can
say, oh now the NSA
can collect all your
traffic and index it
into a very ugly GUI
like this that you see.
So what are people
doing about this?
Sorry this is a little
bit small to see.
But I used to work at the EFF,
Electronic Frontier Foundation.
And about a year
ago we asked people,
we asked major service
websites which of these things
do you support?
So the categories are,
encrypt data center links,
support HTTPS on your website,
support HTTP Strict Transport
Security, support [INAUDIBLE]
with forward secrecy,
and support STARTTLS, which is
transit encryption for mail.
And when we started,
there was a lot more red.
And I don't have a
before slide, but you
can see we have
a lot more green.
And we have a lot more
companies that say,
we're working on this.
Plan quarter two 2014,
this is in progress.
And people don't
often talk about email
when they talk about HTTPS,
but it's also really important.
So we've also seen that
since December 2013,
email encryption has
risen about 33% to 58%.
And now people are saying,
oh web traffic encryption
has more than doubled after
some of the NSA revelations.
So more exciting things
are happening this year.
So WordPress is moving
to support SSL fully,
and that's a huge percentage
of traffic as well.
But what else is going on
other than HTTPS support
becoming much more
popular these days?
So Chromium and
Firefox, the browsers
are implementing WebCrypto.
In fact, I think Chrome
37 is out already, right?
So this has already passed.
So this will allow
people to more easily do
Crypto in a browser,
which we see
more and more of these days.
So a more interesting--
sorry, not more interesting,
but another thing
that's happening
is up HTTP public key pinning.
So websites will be able to
say, these are the certificate
authorities we
expect you to see,
or these are the certificates
that we expect you to see.
And so Firefox 32
now supports that.
Another cool initiative is
certificate transparency.
So how many people here
are familiar with that?
Very few.
So essentially,
certificate transparency
guarantees that if you see
a certificate from a CA
it is publicly logged.
And people can go back,
and check those logs,
and detect attacks.
And this helps
mitigate the problem
that any CA can issue a bad
certificate for you currently.
And Chris Palmer and other
people at Google security
are saying, let's create
greater incentives for people
to support HTTPS and
prefer secure origins
for powerful new web features.
And so secure as HTTPS,
secure web sockets,
and local protocols as well.
So local IPs, rather.
And I'm sure Mark will
say a lot more about this,
but HTTP/2 is out.
And one of the big questions
is, should encryption
be the default?
Should we still have to
think about setting up
SSL certificates?
Or should it just
be automatically
part of the protocol and
something that is inherent
that you have to use if
you're going to use HTTP/2?
But not everything's great.
So we saw with Heartbleed
earlier this year
that certificate revocation
is still very hard to do.
And this is a very
funny diagram that
shows-- so the number of sites
that reissued certificates
after Heartbleed is 43%, but
only 20% revoked certificates.
And of those, 7% issued
the same private key
that was compromised, by
Heartbleed presumably,
was reissued in the certificate.
So the point of this
is that SSL management
is very hard for people, right?
Even with Heartbleed, which
everyone said was a disaster,
we didn't react as
well as we could,
as people who maintain
servers and so forth.
So another thing that keeps
happening is password breaches.
And we'll talk about why
passwords are so difficult.
But I think for
most of us, we don't
realize how hard passwords
are for the average person
until we see these leaked
password breach data.
So this is from the Adobe
one earlier this year.
Oh, we're at Adobe.
I didn't even think about that.
Oops.
So Adobe was
encrypting passwords
instead of salting
and hashing them.
So it was fairly easy to
do statistical analysis
and get the plain
text passwords back.
And so what people
don't realize was
what might not have been obvious
is that people's password
hints, which may not be
stored encrypted at all,
are often just their password.
So even if you're doing
salting and hashing,
peoples' password
hints say 1-2-3-4-5-6,
and that's their password
a lot of the time.
Or rhymes with 'assword' is
probably password, right?
So what's our user model here?
We have to think about people
who are not good at passwords.
And what are some ways we
can either make passwords
better or replace them?
And I don't know if
we'll talk about this,
but something that has
been in the news a lot
lately is third party
tracking in browsers.
So this is from a while
ago, but a question
is what browsers implement
third party cookie blocking?
Even if there's
so much incentive
for advertisers to use
this sort of tracking?
So what can browsers do?
So that's a comic.
And none of this
was about identity,
but you can still
ask about identity
because that's in the
title of the session.
Yeah, sorry Chris.
Cool, that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL COATES: Great, well
why don't we just dive in here?
I mean, a lot of the topics
that you mentioned down
in current events talk
about SSL encryption.
It seems like a no brainer.
We don't want our data to
be exposed in the clear.
We don't want governments
to monitor what we do.
We don't want our
passwords-- regardless
of how they're stored, which
is a whole other issue-- just
to be handed out to everyone
next to us at a coffeehouse.
So our first question along this
topic comes from Andrew Betts
and is, setting up
SSL is too hard today.
What is the single
biggest cause of this?
And what can we do to make
it much easier and faster?
And to continue
along with this, Yan,
why don't you give us
some of your thoughts?
YAN ZHU: Sure.
So I think setting
up SSL varies--
the complexity of the process
varies a lot depending
on whether you're just someone
with a one page website
or if you're a company
like Yahoo or Twitter.
But let's say with the simpler
case, where you're just
someone with a website
who wants to set up
SSL, still a large
number of steps.
So you have to go
to a website, you
have to pick a
certificate authority,
buy it, make sure you put
it in the right folder,
restart your server,
and all that.
And so I think something
that's really great
is that CDNs like
CloudFlare-- I don't
know if I should call them
a CDN in this context--
but they're thinking about
providing free SSL to all
their customers and making
that setup process automatic.
And there are several
other organizations
are-- like for
instance, if you're
a payment site like
Stripe you might say,
we want all of our
customers to use SSL.
So why don't we make
it as easy as possible
and make it a one-click process?
So that's something people
have been thinking about
is one-click SSL setup
for the very simple case.
MICHAEL COATES: And
Mark, do you think
we should have to go through
any of this effort at all?
Should it just be the de
facto of how we do things?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Well, we've
talked about that a lot
in the ITF in terms of making
it the default for HTTP/2.
There's the administrative load
of getting the cert configured,
there's the load of modifying
your content-- which
for a lot of people is
where most of the work is.
If you have a lot of
content, it changes the way
the web security model works.
Once you get past those-- that's
a transition phase you need
to go through-- it
becomes a lot easier.
And I know there are
some efforts out there
to make all of this easier.
There's bettercrypto.org,
which is,
how do you set up good crypto?
People are working
on making it easier
to install the cert on the
server with NPM libraries,
or whatever.
Sorry, what was the question?
MICHAEL COATES:
Should individuals
have to be doing this?
If it's hard?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Are you asking
about opportunistic security?
Are we going there already?
So one of the
proposals out there
is to use what we call
opportunistic security,
to use TLS under the covers
but not change the URL,
keep it HTTP.
Not change the security
context and [? Olock ?] icon.
It's just protecting
against passive attacks.
MIKE WEST: To me
that's a terrible idea.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Well, this
has been very controversial,
I was about to say.
MIKE WEST: To me,
it doesn't actually
remove any of the burden of
setting up anything, right?
You still have to
generate a cert,
you still have to install
it on your server.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: But you can
do all of that automatically.
A good service
with implementation
can do that without any
intervention whatsoever.
MIKE WEST: If you
look at sslmate.com,
they actually have an API
to generate normal certs
that you can also automate.
So it's not the case that only--
MARK NOTTINGHAM: But you still
have you install the cert.
MIKE WEST: Yeah, of course.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: And
so I'm not arguing
for opportunistic security.
I think it's interesting.
The Mozilla guys
are playing with it.
I'd say it's experimental
from their standpoint.
I know the Chrome security
guys are raining down hellfire,
I would say is
probably a good way.
They really don't like it.
And I can understand
that, because it
reduces the deployment of TLS.
And I think we have broad
agreement of most people
on the panel that more
deployment of HTTPS and TLS
is a very good thing.
The places where it
gets a lot harder
are things like internet
of things, or your printer,
or something on
your local network.
That's really hard.
And I think that
part of the community
needs a lot more love.
It's easy to say, oh yes, we're
going to get to that one day,
but I don't see the
browsers focusing on it yet.
NATASHA ROONEY: So if
content providers still
need to go in and
install a certificate,
the how does it ease
the situation for them?
What is easier for them?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Because they
don't have to get it signed.
It doesn't have to be signed
by a certificate authority.
So it can be
generated by code, it
can be installed and
configured by code.
The idea is that from an
administrator's circumstance,
you don't do anything.
It just happens.
And so that is easier, because
the administrative load is not
nothing yet.
MIKE WEST: You don't do
anything except setting up
all the machinery
such that it works.
I can't get away from
the idea that you still
have to do the work to generate
certificates and install them.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: No.
MIKE WEST: You have to
set up the scripts, right?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: No
MIKE WEST: Yes.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: A good
implementation-- and again,
this implementation
does not yet exist--
MIKE WEST: OK, so.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Well
because I don't even
know if it's in
Firefox Nightly yet.
I have to ask Patrick.
But the idea would be
that the server side would
generate the cert on its own
and configure it on its own.
Right now, the problem is
the out-of-the-box Apache
or [? iOS ?] or whatever
configuration is not the best
configuration.
It's the default.
It would be a huge
win for us all
if the defaults were
better, but this
is a fight that has happened
in those communities
for a long time.
They're not quite there yet.
MIKE WEST: So what is the value
of opportunistic encryption,
given that it can be
completely removed
by dropping a
single HTTP header?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Right.
You have a downgrade attack, you
have men in the middle attacks,
any active attack can take over.
And the question is,
what are the consequences
of the attacker going active?
And how willing are they going
to be to go attack active?
So most of the attacks we've
seen exposed by [? Sedona ?]
have been passive.
Jacob Applebaum
argues very strongly
that having protection against
those passive attacks is a win.
But yes, we know that
some state actors
are very willing to go active.
MIKE WEST: I wouldn't
even say state actors.
You have ISPs that are injecting
JavaScript and reconfiguring
your everythings,
which is not awesome.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: And the
interesting thing to me
is that leaves evidence.
When they go active, you can
tell they've gone active.
And what's really
interesting is,
you were referring to
the Comcast ad injection.
And there's been a reaction to
that, but as far as I'm aware,
they're still doing it.
It's not like they've been
stopped by people going,
oh no, they're
putting ads in there.
But they're still doing it
MIKE WEST: That's
kind of my point,
is that it's not
just state actors
that we need to worry about.
It's really anyone
between you and the server
that you want to [INAUDIBLE].
MARK NOTTINGHAM: And that's
what I worry about in all
of this in both
directions is acclimation.
When users get used to their
security being degraded,
or they just come to expect
well that's just how things work
on the internet, we're
all in a worse place.
MIKE WEST: I completely agree.
MICHAEL COATES: So I'd love
to get some people queued up
in the audience with
some thoughts on SSL.
So ring in and we'll get
some microphones your way.
Let's go ahead and get to a
couple of those out there.
In the meantime,
before this exists,
anything we can do to
make it easier today?
MIKE WEST: So like I
said, I think sslmate.com
is a website that I think
is really interesting,
because they're starting to put
an API in front of certificate
generation.
So you have a script
on your server,
you say please generate
me a new certificate,
and it does the work of using
the key or generating a key,
and then going out, generating
the CSR, grabbing a cert,
and doing all the
work for you, which
I think is a really
interesting model.
I'd like to see more of that.
What I'd really
like to see is work
being done by the providers.
So it's not something
that I think
browser vendors are really
well placed to solve.
It's something
that I think needs
to be done at a server level
and at a provider level.
So when someone like Wordpress,
or something like CloudFlare
does work and submits patches
back to the open source
systems, I think that's a
really healthy relationship.
And I'd like to see
more of that happening.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: I'd like
to see the Apache plug-ins,
and just to make those
really easy to use together.
CHRIS MESSINA: Actually,
one more thing on that.
So my friend
[INAUDIBLE] last night
pointed out that in the
Indyweb organization
and community have
worked on this.
And they've got a bunch
of documentation up
at indyweb.org/https if you want
to put it on your own servers.
So there's some efforts
in that sense as well.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: It's kind
of like better crypto.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
The same sort of idea.
MICHAEL COATES: Out to the
audience, we've got Guy.
There we are.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to point out
that there's the technical
aspect of installing it,
but there's also the
certificate validation,
which is part of the pain point.
And I think there the
challenges are very different.
I mean, if you do
domain validation
you can see automation
and making that very easy.
But when you're talking about
organizational validation,
or extended
validation, those are
processes that at least today
are part of the trust model
we're educating our users
about with all sorts of signals
on the browser.
And as long as we're
there, then there's
somebody that needs to call
up or look up another person.
At least in the Akamai
experience, a lot of times
those are the bottlenecks
versus the technologies.
CHRIS MESSINA: And I guess I'd
claim that those have no value.
That friction is
actually part of the--
AUDIENCE: They
may have no value,
but if that is the
claim, then they
need to provide an
alternative or claim what
it is that you are giving up.
MIKE WEST: Yeah, I think from
my perspective domain validation
is enough.
Like if I prove that
I own the domain
and in pin the
cert to my domain,
proving that I totally
own it, then that's fine.
I don't need EV, I
don't need a green bar.
There's really no value
to that whatsoever.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: You
mean PIN or HSTS?
MIKE WEST: Both.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: So I
pin my cert to my domain.
Is your browser
acknowledging that pin?
MIKE WEST: I don't know
if public key pins has
shipped as a header.
I know that we support
public key pins
in the pre-load list in
both Chrome and Firefox now.
I would have to ask folks
whether we support it
on the open web.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: I think
it's not yet supported.
YAN ZHU: I think Chrome has
basic support for the header,
but Firefox has not.
MIKE WEST: Right.
But regardless, that's going
to happen at some point.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: But you can get
yourself in trouble with that
too.
You can put yourself
in a place where
you've locked all of your users
out of your [INAUDIBLE] server.
MIKE WEST: And
that's kind of bad.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
And I feel like we
need even more best
practices around all this,
because the process of getting
a cert and configuring it,
and all these different little
tiny holes you can get yourself
in is still very confusing, even
to someone who does this a lot.
We can do a lot better.
MICHAEL COATES: Great.
Let's see here,
we've got to Alex.
AUDIENCE: So Mark,
to your point I'm
very curious to know
what folks on the stage
or the organizations
you work for are
doing to make it much easier to
get a system image-- like a dmg
or something-- for a
VM and just get it up
and running with good security.
Because today my experience
is that if you take an Ubuntu
image and you set it up.
And you set up Apache
and you attempt
to get your site
encrypted, you're
going to end up with a
very bad configuration.
You're going to have the
wrong order for cipher suites.
You're going to have no HSTS.
You're just going to be pretty
much boned out of the box
until you figure out all of
these little fiddly bits.
What can we do to make it so
that the distro vendors have
some skin in the game here?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: So
that's a good question.
So when I switched my site to
HTTPS, I followed better crypto
and deviated slightly from it.
But we have guards
like better crypto,
we have the SSL
labs tester which
is a great resource-- I wish
that it was a little easier
for people to find.
But actually
convincing the distros,
my experience is you
go to the distros
and you make these arguments--
or you going to Apache
and you make these arguments
about the defaults.
And there tends to be-- I don't
want to pick on any one party
here, but there tends
to be a lot of pushback.
That, oh well we
have legacy reasons,
we have compatibility
reasons, we
have these huge groups of
users we need to consider.
And it's like, well
that's not good enough.
This is 2014, Edward
Snowden happened,
and you're still
shipping something
that's insecure by default
because you want 0.2% better
interoperability with
IE5, or whatever it is.
I really think we can
do better than that.
But I think that takes a
coordinated effort by the web
community to go
to those operating
systems and another
communities and say, no this
isn't good enough.
And we haven't
quite seen that yet.
MICHAEL COATES: Well, we'll
go ahead and wrap this one up.
I heard a few good
ideas to take home.
The future of
opportunistic encryption,
that will be good
when we get there.
There will be some challenges.
I heard SSL Mate, SSL
Labs, and Indyweb.
So some interesting items
to take home on that.
So jumping right along,
no shortage of security
challenges in the
world or internet.
This next question paraphrased
from-- I'll try my best--
Uav Weiss.
Passwords are increasingly
seen as an anti-pattern.
What are ideal alternatives?
And Chris, you spend a
lot of time with identity.
What has your experience
brought you to on this area?
CHRIS MESSINA: It
is sad that we keep
talking about being in 2014.
And I feel like the last
time I worked on this problem
was seven years ago.
And there was a person
seven years before me
that worked on it, and
back to the stone age.
So it just doesn't seem
to be a problem that
is going to solve
itself, certainly.
And I think the similar to the
problem that you're pointing
out, and that Alex is
pointing out with the distros,
it comes down to economics,
behavioral economics as well as
business model economics.
The password
anti-pattern is something
that we identified
when APIs were first
starting to be
released in the 2005
to 2007 era of the
golden web, back when
they drove big cars
with whaleskin hubcaps.
Sorry if you don't
get that reference,
it's even longer than that.
Anyway, the problem of course,
is it's really easy for users
to remember one little string.
Of course, if they put it in the
password recovery field anyway,
then it's-- that's an
amazing slide, by the way.
Anyway, back when
APIs were getting out,
Basic was the only way
to do this authentication
against these different
service providers.
And the problem was that users
would reuse the same password
everywhere.
And so this became a
password anti-pattern,
because if any one of
those chains was broken,
effectively all of your
security was then screwed.
And so we started a campaign
in conjunction with OpenID
to try to get people
to switch over
to something that was more of
a centralized authentication
model.
And so your OpenID provider--
your identity provider--
essentially could be as
secure as you want it to be
or as insecure as you
chose to allow it to be.
So if you chose not to have a
password on your OpenID server,
you could do that.
It would just be
an open redirector,
and people did that the
prove that OpenID was broken,
or whatever.
The problem though is
that getting people
to change their behavior or
to understand the risks that
are actually out
there in the world,
or to make them even
stop for a moment
to think that if they
pick up their device
they're opening themselves up
to all sorts of vulnerabilities
is something that actually
just crushes the entire world
and universe.
And their mind sort of melts.
And as a UX designer,
it's really difficult
to try to address that problem
through user education,
for example.
By telling them that
this is a terrible thing.
So the ways in which you
may-- I'll give you some
answers-- the ways in
which you may address
this would be through
two-factor authentication,
through behavioral tracking--
so understanding the user's
behavior-- through
third party validation,
or-- I had another
one but I forget.
So there you go.
MICHAEL COATES: There's
a lot going on here.
CHRIS MESSINA: There's a lot.
MICHAEL COATES:
We'll pause on that.
Natasha, can mobile help?
We've got this
device in our pocket.
Does it help us at all here?
NATASHA ROONEY: Yeah.
There's a few things that are
happening within this area
right now.
And initially I was a little
bit skeptical about this,
about moving something
from being in the cloud
and being able to log
into various services
wherever you are, to going
to being reliant on perhaps
some hardware token or
some piece of hardware.
But you're right, it's true
that many of us, or most of us,
are carrying a mobile
around with us.
Some people now have
watches that they
are using as well
in a similar way.
So there is some argument
to say that why don't we
utilize those
things that allow us
to log into various services?
And on top of the stuff
that was happening
at OpenID Connect and
the Oauth stuff in ITF,
there's a lot of work going
on with another organization
called the FIDO Alliance which
is using a PKI to actually do
the authentication to
allow you to log in.
But when you log in, you
do something on the device.
So it sends a challenge
to the device.
And then the device can ask
you to identify yourself
through that challenge.
But it could be anything.
It could be a fingerprint scan.
It could be a password.
It could be an interpretive
dance, it doesn't matter.
It could be anything.
It's what that
device chooses to be
and what you decide to then use.
And then the PKR
would then go through,
and then you're able to
log in to view the site.
But Chris is right,
getting users
to accept this is
very difficult.
I know Mozilla had a
really great system
with their Persona.
And what happened to that
was really quite unfortunate.
The technology was
really fantastic,
but users just didn't get it.
He's right, they didn't get it.
And that sort of died
out because of that,
and it was a shame.
So maybe that's where we need
to focus our methods on is that.
MIKE WEST: Do you
think thats-- do
you think that's a technology
problem or a UI problem?
NATASHA ROONEY: See, I think
it probably is the UI problem.
But I'm not too sure
if I'd described it
as UI or educational.
OK, well maybe by the look on
your face it's the same thing.
So it was getting
them to understand
that this was still safe.
I think many, many standard
users will go ahead and think,
I should put in a username and
I should put in a password.
That is secure.
If I'm clicking something
and it's allowing me in,
that's not something
I want to use.
That's insecure.
And then going back
to the HTTP argument,
I think that most users
would ignore the bar
and would ignore HTTP.
And they want to see
a username and they
want to see a password.
And that to them
triggers secure.
And they'll think that
is more secure than HTTPS
in a big green bar and a
button to say just log in.
That just, it just doesn't work.
MIKE WEST: So would we
solve these problems
if we have a magical system
that generates strong passwords
for users and saves
them in some way?
Like the password managers
that are built into browsers?
NATASHA ROONEY: I don't know.
I like password managers,
but I like password managers
right now.
I think it's a good
stopgap to move forward,
and I think more
of the future stuff
is more of this OpenID Connect,
FIDO Alliance, more PKI, more
of the stuff that
Mozilla was trying to do.
But that almost just came
a little bit too early.
So I think we should
still push for that.
But OK, so going back
to your original point,
yes it's a UI thing.
Maybe we just need to
make it a little bit more
obvious and a little bit
more easy for those users
to understand.
CHRIS MESSINA: It's also a
timing and context thing.
Again, the API interoperability
and integration
between lots of different
apps and services
was a big driver and pusher
for a lot, for example.
And that previous pattern
had to be defeated.
The things that are happening
now with mobile, and touch ID,
and stuff like that
I think are going
to train a generation of users
to not only hate passwords,
but to not want to
type ever, ever again.
And they'll only
talk to their device,
like in "Star
Trek" or something.
And if you're speaking your
plain text password, which
is no more plain
text as plain speech,
that doesn't make sense either.
So we have to migrate to
where users are going.
We've in some ways lived in
the future about our security
awareness for a long time,
using stone age tools
to authenticate ourselves.
But I think as
devices get better,
and they become more ubiquitous,
and users' expectations
change on how they actually
interact with the devices, that
creates this opportunity to
actually implement things that
were relevant 10 years ago now.
It's just that it
hasn't lined up yet.
MICHAEL COATES: If you look at
the adoption of the fingerprint
scanners on iPhones, is
that the direction forward?
The user doesn't have
to think about anything
but just touch this.
And perhaps that's tied
into a password manager.
Is this the direction
we're going?
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Well
that's tied into Apple.
I mean, you're owned
by Apple there.
CHRIS MESSINA: Will just
evaluate the UX though.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Sure.
But I think becoming
successful because it's Apple.
CHRIS MESSINA: What's
also interesting about it
though is that it creates a
type of-- it's interesting.
There's a behavioral
element to it
where you can actually have
multiple fingerprints that
are authenticated to a device.
So for example, if I have
kids, or if I have a spouse,
or whatever, and I want them
to be able to authenticate
purchases, I don't have
to share a password.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Wait,
is that with the iOS 8?
CHRIS MESSINA: Well, so
there's family sharing, which
is actually addressing the--
YAN ZHU: MARK NOTTINGHAM:
Because you just
sold me a new iPhone
if that's the case.
CHRIS MESSINA: Yeah.
So the family
sharing thing will be
interesting to see how
that actually works,
in terms of shared
authentication.
But you could actually
add multiple fingers,
which you didn't have to own.
So I could have had your
finger and my finger.
I'm just saying,
all of a sudden we
have a very interesting
touch device.
But the point is, it allows
for a different way of managing
passwords which people do.
People share their
Amazon passwords.
One of the biggest things that
I've noticed about-- oh, I
saw this in the reviews
for "Find My Friends."
If you guys go to the
app store, check it out.
There's a lot of
one star reviews,
because people would say that
actually I allowed my spouse
to log in under my account
using the same password,
and you've removed that feature.
So the sharing of a password
is removing a feature.
And so if you have to do
two-factor authentication,
you've actually
disabled functionality
that people rely on.
There's a greater context
here that I think needs.
MICHAEL COATES: Let's get an
audience member lined up too.
NATASHA ROONEY:
That spans the point
about having multiple
assurance levels, almost.
So you say, logging
into my phone
might be-- I have
password protected
a lot of the more insecure
applications on my phone.
So I just want to
log into my phone
really quickly
because I just want
to tell when I need
to turn left next,
or turn right, or check a
text message, or whatever.
But there's going to be other
things like looking at my bank
account which I want to
be very, very secure.
And in which case, then those
different assurance levels
need to come in.
And there needs to be methods.
And people are looking at
methods there to focus on that.
And it's not just about
multiple different passwords
or copying out the number
on the front of your card,
but having those
different levels
and different types with
different resources.
MICHAEL COATES: Ada?
Perfect, what have
you got for us?
AUDIENCE: You can assume
that your password is
available from a database you
can purchase online matched
to your favorite
usernames and emails.
So is it even useful
to use a password
in a world in which you can
use two-factor authentication?
CHRIS MESSINA: Yes.
I mean, part of it
again is cost, right?
So if you're building
an application,
or if you're building
a stupid-- I'm not
going to name any names--
iOS app, for example,
and you just want to get
something out the door.
Security is not a big deal.
You basically want
to avoid someone else
taking a selfie on
your behalf, right?
You don't necessarily
need to throw
in two-factor authentication
and put that huge speed bump in.
You're going to have such
a grade of loss of signups.
Even where it's like,
connect with Twitter
to log in or whatever, that
extra speed bump actually
inhibits adoption a lot.
So again from a cost
benefit analysis,
I think you have to look at
it from that perspective.
MICHAEL COATES: We've
got a lot interest.
I'm going to take on another
topic here before we move on.
Guy, over there.
AUDIENCE: I just want
to talk a little bit
about continuous authentication.
So we've named a lot of
things, and all the wearables,
and those components, still
everything you talked about
was around prompted
authentication
where somebody logs in.
Granted, it's easier to put
your finger to something
than type in a
password or voice it.
But still, do we need something
that constantly tracks us--
not in the privacy sense of
the word, but rather locally
and authenticates.
CHRIS MESSINA: I
mean, absolutely.
And the difference is,
who is doing the tracking?
AUDIENCE: This is not
necessarily communicated out.
I mean, this is
just something local
that takes a biometric
indicator or some other form.
Maybe it's the presence of
a device or whatever it is.
But it's a little
bit more continuous.
So as I take the right turn,
I don't need to be stopped.
I think eventually the user's
goal is not to be secure.
It's to complete whatever it is
the action that they're doing.
So we need security to be
as seamless as possible
as a part of that.
And that may imply
something that
doesn't require prompting them.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: The credit
card companies already do this.
They track where you
are to figure out
what credit card
purchases make sense.
I was in Istanbul two weeks
ago, and somebody's credit card
didn't work.
And so they went
and called the bank,
and the bank said, oh yeah,
we can see you're in Istanbul
and you're leaving on
such and such date.
And the thing is, they
hadn't told the bank
that they were going
to make that trip.
The airline company shared
the ticket data with the bank
automatically.
And it wasn't opt in.
And so that's like--
CHRIS MESSINA: Oh I'm
sure there was an opt in.
You just check the box.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Oh yeah,
there's a box way down deep
or there's an opt out.
But they didn't
remember doing it.
CHRIS MESSINA: The
terms were in there.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Right, in
that 14,000 pages of text.
And so that's a really
interesting world
to live in, because the
European people I was with
were freaking out.
They were like, that's illegal.
I was freaking out.
I live in Australia,
that's illegal.
But in the US, hey
that's convenient.
That's OK.
MICHAEL COATES: Well,
we've got a lot of topics,
a lot of interest on
this one but we're
going to keep charging forward.
I'm not surprised
that there's plenty
of opinions on passwords.
And some of the things I've
heard so far though is we
really have to work
on usability and make
it seamless and appropriate.
Easy when it needs
to be and even more
robust when it needs to be.
Moving on, our third question
comes from Ben Vinegar.
Google Now uses HTTPS
as a ranking signal
and Server Worker is HTTPS only.
Both are likely to
increase HTTPS adoption.
Are there other
security-minded features
that should incentivized
in this manner?
And so it feels like as
we take this question,
we're shifting slightly
away from the security
that only users face,
like passwords, but more
to what should our
applications and websites
be doing automatically?
Because the sad
reality is, they're
doing just as much as they need
to, and maybe not even that.
But this seems like
an incentive model
that may make them want
to do more for security.
MIKE WEST: Sure.
I think it's a really
interesting idea by the search
team to start promoting
in a small way HTTPS.
I think that there are search
related reasons that they
do this, because you need to
ensure that the content you're
delivering to the user is
actually the content that you
expect to be
delivered to the user.
So it HTTPS gives you
some sort of verification
that you are in fact
talking to cnn.com
and you're not talking to the
NSA who's injecting stories
about how awesome the NSA is
onto the front page of cnn.com.
CHRIS MESSINA: To
make you happier.
MIKE WEST: To make
you happier, exactly.
So I think that there are
search quality related reasons
to do this particular action.
I don't think it's only
about promoting HTTPS.
I think that there
are other reasons.
So I think that for search
engines in particular,
you would have to find other
quality related reasons
that you would promote.
And one of those might
be mixed content.
So if you have mixed
content on the page,
then you are in fact degrading
the quality of the HTTPS
encryption, because you're
loading insecure resources
into a secure context.
So perhaps we could
start looking at that.
HSTS would be nice.
Because then you can ensure
that there's-- Strict Transport
Security means that you can't
execute a downgrade attack.
You can't force someone onto
HTTP from an HTTPS website.
You say, this website
should always be HTTPS.
That gives a pretty
solid guarantee
that you are in fact
talking to the server
that you expect
to be talking to.
So these sorts of
things are things
that would be nice to
promote in some way.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: And
on the standard side,
there's more and
more capabilities
that people are talking about
making HTTPS only or preferring
HTTPS.
And I think a lot of
that's because Google
or the Chrome team recently
brought up that policy which
was proposing amongst
other browsers
that powerful new facilities
are by default secure or only
secure.
And I think that's
because there's
a lot of subtlety to security,
where people say oh, I
don't need HTTPS for that
because I'm doing this, and not
realizing that there are lots
of other very subtle attack
vectors.
Or it might be the
user themselves
that wants the security
rather than the site
and its content
wanting the security.
The use case that comes
up in the ITF-- and there
was actually a draft
about this as well--
imagine the search engine.
And that's public data
that you're getting.
So it doesn't have
the inherent issues
around the data you're getting.
But if you're a gay
teenager in Nigeria,
and you're searching about being
gay, and or AIDS or whatever,
that can get you killed.
And so security really does
matter there for reasons
that the service provider
might not anticipate.
MICHAEL COATES: Why don't
we jump out to the audience?
We have Mark?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
is the obsession with web
performance setting
back security practices?
And are there rampant
misconceptions about the trade
off between security
and performance
that you feel need
to be corrected?
MIKE WEST: So Illy [? is ?]
in the audience somewhere.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: Yeah,
if [? Illy ?] is here,
just give him the mic.
MIKE WEST: So anyway,
he has a great website
called istlsfast.com?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE WEST: Is TLS fast yet.
I'm sorry, istlsfastyet.com.
And that answers
some of the questions
around the speed impact of TLS.
And I think that [? Illy's ?]
got a really great resource
there, so I would highly
recommend that you read it.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: It answers
all the questions, pretty much.
NATASHA ROONEY: There's some
work going on in this area
though.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
There's TLS 1.3,
and that's trying to get down
to zero round trip or one round
trip.
NATASHA ROONEY: And FastOpen.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
Well that's TLS 1.3.
MIKE WEST: And there's
experimentation with protocols
as well.
So if you look at
Quick, they're also
trying to do zero round trip.
And that's based on
a different thing
that I don't remember that was
also doing something similar.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
There's a lot of talk
about UDP based HTTP in general.
And that's again about
performance while
not trading off security.
NATASHA ROONEY: There were
some use cases though mentioned
in HTTP [INAUDIBLE] about
there being some slow-- well,
for people that
perhaps use satellite
connections and stuff.
And that causes a massive issue,
the current situation with TLS.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
There are certainly
some unusual
deployment scenarios.
That's more about
those people wanting
to get inside and do
optimizations on the data
and not being able
to do that when
there's encryption present.
And that opens a whole other
can of worms about security
and the relationships
happening there.
MICHAEL COATES: It's certainly
an interesting question
is that tying it back to
the incentivizing HTTPS.
If we incentivize
security, we have
to overcome the perceptions
of those challenges.
CHRIS MESSINA: And
realities in some cases.
MICHAEL COATES: And
realities, exactly.
MARK NOTTINGHAM: And I
think we're working on it.
MICHAEL COATES: Jonas.
There comes the mic.
AUDIENCE: HTML also has some
weird, old anti-features,
where back in the day HTTPS was
considered the bank websites
technology.
And so it turns off
things like referrers
and does various
other things that I
don't know off the
top of my head.
There is work to fix
some of these things.
So there's a
meta-referrer spec now
where you say that
even though I'm HTTPS,
I'm actually just
a normal website.
Please send referral links.
But I suspect there's
more work like that
that needs to be done as well.
MARK NOTTINGHAM:
Yeah, there's a lot
of different parts of
the web security model
that hang off of that decision
to have that little S there.
And yeah, I agree it would
be nice to pick that apart
a little bit where
it's appropriate.
MICHAEL COATES: Let's see, we
have one more person up there.
Patrick, there we are,
up here in the front.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Natasha
mentioned earlier one
of the issues with
Persona failing
was users inherently not
thinking it was secure
because you weren't
entering a password.
So I was wondering, how much
does security theater come
into play when designing secure
interfaces and making things
think they're secure as
opposed to being secure.
SPEAKER 1: UX as security
theater, I guess?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
We do our best to, in
browsers, promote the things
that we know to be secure,
and promote the things that
help us make things more secure.
So there is absolutely security
theater in the browser,
like the EB certificates
that we talked about earlier.
They are completely
the same encryption
as normal certificates,
but they're green.
So they must be better, right?
That sort of thing
is good because it
helps us do things like CT.
It helps us work better with
certificate authorities.
So doing those sorts of things
as kind of harmless security
theater is kind of OK.
But generally speaking, we
want to build interfaces
that promote the things
that are actually secure
and make the guarantees that
we know we can actually make.
So I hope that we
don't do things
that are strictly
security theater.
But I definitely think that we
need to think about the ways
that users interact
with web pages
and interact with the
user agent in order
to ensure that the
behaviors that we promote
are in fact the ones we
want to promotes, and not
the alternative.
SPEAKER 3: Part
of the problem is
there's a huge generation
of people that have grown up
expecting username and password,
password being concealed,
as being the way to understand
that something is actually
safe.
So for example, one of
experiments that we did back
in the OpenID
days-- because you'd
just type in the URL and that
[INAUDIBLE] authenticate.
But you could type
in an email address,
and there'd be a
password box beneath it.
And of course, we would
drop off the username.
And we'd drop off the
password, and we'd just sort of
ignore those things and
drop them on the floor,
and send you over to
the URL that you'd
typed in as your email address.
It was somewhat
confusing to users,
but that meant that
those services that
were willing to
participate in that
were actually preserving
a little more of the user
security by not creating
another surface area for them
to be exposed in entering
the same password again.
So it's not perfect,
but in some ways,
tricking people into
being more secure,
if it actually converts better,
is a better thing to do.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Well, I'll pause
on that, because we're actually
going to get into it even more
in this very next question.
SPEAKER 3: Great.
MALE SPEAKER 4: But it
sounds like there's consensus
that incentivizing security
is really pretty good.
I didn't hear any
objections at all.
SPEAKER 1: I think it's
really hard on mobile,
like UX on mobile
is not there yet.
SPEAKER 3: Efficiency
is so important.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 4: OK.
Good, so in terms of
the original question,
other features, it
sounds like mixed content
might be a next one to
start charging down.
If we're going to incentivize
SSL, let's take it
to the next degree and make
sure it's a good SSL connection.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah, note that
I an not on the search team,
for clarity.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Great.
So I'm going to move onto
our next question brought
to us by Matt Andrews.
"What signals should
the browser communicate
to users regarding
their security,"
so no doubt diving into UX
security theater or not.
"For example,
should we warn users
about personal
information submissions?
Should imperfect HTTPS
be flagged differently
than plain HTTP?
What would a non-techie
user respond to?"
And Yan, I think with your
work on HTTPS Everywhere
and some of those items, this
might be very relevant for you.
YAN: Yeah, well, I think
the answer to this question
is hugely different, depending
on whether the user is
someone technical who knows what
mixed content is versus someone
who barely knows what the
Lock icon means, right?
There's only so many
icons you can put there
before people just
say like, I don't
understand what this icon means.
I'm going to ignore
the square entirely.
So my theory is we've already
saturated at that point,
and we can't really
add any more icons.
SPEAKER 3: Peak disclosure.
YAN: Yeah, I don't
know what else.
So one thing I did work on at
EFF that's tangentially related
is displaying to people
when third parties
are tracking them.
So yeah, this is also
a security feature,
not in the same way as HTTPS.
But if you think
about how much data
you're leaking to third
parties, in often cases,
that's a security risk.
And it turns out
people do really
like seeing what third
parties are tracking them.
And I think Mozilla has done
some work with a project called
Lightbeam to help people
see what the connections are
between the various first
party sites they're visiting
and the third party sites.
So that's a cool
space to move in.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, that can also
be tackled regulatory-- I know
this is a technical conference.
So I'll just spend a
little bit of time on that.
At least in Japan,
it's a guideline.
It's not actually law,
but there's a guideline
to say that any application
that takes any personal data
or basically uses
any permissions
needs to state to the user,
before they download it,
what permission is being
taken, what data's being taken,
who that data then gets
sent to, and roughly
what that data is
going to be used for.
So there is some regulation
going on in that area.
It would be better if it
was tackled technically.
But that's an interesting
case from a different country.
SPEAKER 3: I mean, that's
sort of the tension
between the economics
of the problems that
can result from security
violations or the breakdowns
of things compared with
the overall UX experience,
creating a wonderful
experience-- I think
is this huge enormous tension.
And whether it's
through regulations
or through laws or things like
that that require or demand
certain disclosures to
be made, ultimately,
you're going to be affecting
people's businesses
and business models
and their ability
to actually offer the
services that they're doing.
I don't know where this
actually comes down,
but most users--
and I am somewhat
OCD about looking at
authorization screens.
If you go to my Flickr account,
which is under factoryjoe,
search for "Facebook
authorization." and I
have like all over the
generations of the Facebook
Connect dialogues.
In the beginning, there was lots
of words and lots of disclosure
and tons of information.
And now, of course,
you get to this place
where it's like your face
and your information's
going to be sent over there.
That cool?
They added this
button where it's
like, edit your information.
Most people don't care.
I worked on the Google
authorization dialogues.
It's extremely difficult to
communicate this information
in an efficient, effective
way to get people to care
and to actually be part of
the dialogue and conversation
with-- to understand the
relationship that they're
having with these
different providers.
It becomes just so
over their heads.
And it provides so
little value to what
they're trying to do that
providing this in a [INAUDIBLE]
is difficult.
So that said, there are reactive
ways of dealing with this,
as Google does, where they
send out-- what is it?
Your statement, or
whatever-- your data
access statement or something.
So maybe from an
auditing perspective,
if you have a centralized
identity provider, whether it's
Facebook, Google,
Twitter or whatever, here
are the apps that are
asking for your information.
Here is what we think
they've done with it.
Here are the number
of your friends
who have actually uninstalled
or stopped using these apps.
And here's what
Consumer Reports,
if they were doing
their job in this space,
could tell you about
what's happened to people
who have given their
information to these places.
So there's just not
a lot of other ways
in which we're looking at giving
this information to people
that might be more effective.
MALE SPEAKER 2: And getting
back to the idea of what
we can do in the browser,
I think both of you
were mentioning
that we've already
put too much on the browser.
And I think we should
start taking things away.
For instance, why do we
flag HTTPS as being good?
Why don't we flag
HTTP as being bad?
I think that we can start
making it more clear
that certain
behaviors are good--
or not good, but default.
They should be expected.
And I think both Mozilla and
Google are looking at that bar
and trying to figure out
what we can do in order
to encourage the behaviors
that we think are really secure
and discourage the behaviors
that aren't secure.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Like Yan did the
HTTPS Everywhere-- plugging you
up on that-- but you also get
the HTTP Nowhere extension,
which I love, which
is your browser
will refuse to
navigate to HTTP sites.
And I want to live in a
world where that's normal,
where I don't have to
explain to my wife and kids
that yes, you have to
look for the Lock icon.
And maybe I won't
live in that world.
But maybe my kids
will, you know,
where the web is just
encrypted by default.
And it doesn't work
if it's not encrypted.
It just breaks.
MALE SPEAKER 4: And it really
gets to an interesting question
about this, about what
we should communicate.
Should we ever put
users in a situation
where they're making
security decisions?
SPEAKER 1: Right.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Aren't
they always going
to want the secure path?
SPEAKER 1: Right.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Is there any
reason we should ever ask them?
SPEAKER 1: Well--
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah, I
mean, web sites screw up.
And it's certainly
possible for you
to need to get to a
website, and-- like
for example, Onslyde.
I went to Onslyde this morning.
And Onslyde, the link
was to onslyde.com.
But if you look at
the cert details,
it was for www.onslyde.com.
And I can make that distinction,
and say, well, they're
actually the same thing
and click through.
Chrome is making it
more difficult for me
to click through.
I now have to click on Advanced
and then read some text,
and then down in light gray
text at the bottom of the page,
there's the Continue button.
So we're discouraging that
activity to whatever extent
possible.
And we allow the
server to tell us
that we should
completely disable it.
So if we set up HSTS,
then we won't give you
that option to continue.
Because they had asked
for strict security,
so we're going to give
them strict security.
But for normal web
pages, it's really tough
to make a complete
blocking action,
because the web is a difficult
place and things break.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it sounds
difficult to say that, well, we
will then go ahead and
stop blocking sites.
And the web is
such an open place,
and accessing information
and sharing information
is the idea of the web.
And now we're
saying, oh, no, no,
but we're going to
block these ones.
And the intentions are great.
Don't get me wrong.
It's very hard to
make that decision
to go and say-- so the things
that the Chrome search team are
doing at Google about saying,
OK, well, we'll reorder stuff.
You say, cool, we know
that this is a CNN link.
Great, that's fantastic.
But that's a very
common use case.
But there is a small
percentage chance
that more unreliable data will
reach to the top over the data
that you actually want to find.
So it's a little bit difficult.
We need to think about
it, how it works out.
SPEAKER 3: I would
support that point
from a different
perspective, which
is to say that the web is a
tinkerer's paradise in a sense.
And we're asking people
to take a greater
degree of responsibility for
understanding and knowing
all the different ways
in which it can fail
rather than the ways in which
you can get something out
to the world.
And so I think if you build
a tax on all of the stuff
that we're talking about
to make it safer and better
for everyone, but you increase
the cost of the ability
to publish to it,
then you will have
more people building
native apps.
Because it's cheaper, easier,
and it feels better to do that.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
What we're looking
at is we're embarking
on a very long-term
effort to encourage better
behaviors by default,
to have best practices,
little pushes here and there.
It's not something that's going
to happen overnight or even
in three or four years,
or even five or 10 years.
But it has to happen.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Go
out to audience here.
Dominic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so it's
great that the web is open.
It's great that the
web is open, and we
can use all these
obsolete technologies.
But we can't use
HTTP 0.9 anymore.
We can't use Gopher anymore.
One of these days,
we shouldn't be
able to use unencrypted
HTTP anymore.
And I think that's totally fine.
And as Mark says, it may
be a longer term effort.
But it doesn't worry me.
It doesn't seem like
an openness issue
if you can't use these
legacy technologies, at least
on that level.
I mean, yeah, we're
still trying to kill
showModalDialogue, but whatever.
SPEAKER 3: I mean,
that's a fair point.
Does open mean we
have to leave behind--
we have to keep using all
these things that are horribly
insecure and aren't
helping us at all?
Or can we make progress forward?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, I think
you just need think about,
well, are you going to
use a carrot of a stick?
Like that's the thing, is
that shutting HTTP data off
sounds like a bit of
stick method to me.
I think we need a
few more carrots.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Well,
I guess, my claim
would be that if you
want to use Gopher,
go download a Gopher program.
And you can still
access all the Gopher
servers they're
probably still up.
And you will be taking
that risk, and that's fine.
SPEAKER 1: And again,
it's an incremental thing.
I mean, one of the
things that I've
been talking to people a little
bit about is privacy mode.
If I'm in privacy mode and I go
see an HTTP site-- or some sort
of security-centric mode,
I've given the browser
a signal that hey,
I'm really concerned
about my personal
privacy and security.
Maybe the browser should
not let me use an HTTP site.
So it's kind of an opt-in thing.
It's an incremental
way to get there,
rather than just shutting
it off one night.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so if
I'm-- because one of the things
I was going to say earlier
about I think sometimes,
one of the biggest issues
is users being in a hurry,
like they click through because
I need something right now.
I need to download
Uber right now
because I need a taxi right now.
I don't care.
It doesn't matter what
I'm clicking through.
I need to get someone now.
And that's, I think--
they don't read.
They click through.
And that's a big issue.
SPEAKER 1: And it's
interesting you bring that up.
Yeah, that's true
for a lot of users.
And security people
I talk to sometimes
get into this little bit
of a mindset of absolutism,
where everything has to
be secure all the time.
Whereas for a large number
of users on the planet,
they're willing to
make trade-offs.
And the problem is
they're not educated
about those trade-offs.
There's a smaller
population on the planet who
are very concerned about
security and privacy.
And they have good reason
to be, for various reasons.
And we need to give
them good tools too.
MALE SPEAKER 4: So we'll move
into our next question here.
This next question actually
is going to pull together
a few different ideas we've
talked about about user
experience, SLL, and
the mobile experience--
or at least moving around
where you connect to the net.
So brought to us from Cornell
Lysinski, "What should we
allow intermediaries such
as mobile operator proxies,
Wi-fi hotspots,
corporate gateways,
et cetera, to see and
do to user traffic?"
MALE SPEAKER 2: I
would suggest that we
let them do whatever the
user enables them to do,
or whatever the
administrator who
exerts executive control
over the machine allows,
which basically means
that if it's over HTTPS,
they shouldn't be able
to do anything to it
unless a cert has been
installed in the root
store of the machine.
Because that means that someone
exerted administrative control
over the machine and said,
this is the right thing for you
to do.
Go through this mobile proxy.
That's going to
change everything.
MALE SPEAKER 4: So you're saying
a coffee shop wireless should
not be able to intercept,
do a "man in the middle,"
throw all the warnings, train
people to click through?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Never, ever.
SPEAKER 1: And we've
talked about this a lot
in the HTTP working group.
And that's the model
we've kind of resolved on,
is that HTTPS is explicitly
end-to-end secure.
It's not end-to-end and maybe
this guy comes to the middle
and has a chat.
And so the trust
store in the browser
is a really
fundamental mechanism.
Now, as we were talking
about last night,
we can improve the
trust store a lot.
The user experience around
that is pretty bad right now.
But that's kind of the
model we're working towards.
SPEAKER 3: It occurs
to me again-- I
tend to think about
a lot of things
from an economic perspective.
And there is an economic
benefit or reason
why the coffee shop
would sort of intersperse
their thing with
ads or whatever.
People are unwilling to pay for
Wi-Fi or something like that.
Or if they have
to pay for Wi-Fi,
to be able to get a
line, because people
aren't buying enough coffee.
So I think that the
challenge-- back
to your point about whether
it's a carrot or a stick--
is unclear whether
or not it should
be illegal to break the stuff
and have these captive portals,
in which case, it's a very
different type of enforcement
model.
Or if it's a carrot
thing where it's
like users have a
different attitude
and they just shut down if they
don't want be vulnerable to it.
SPEAKER 1: Personally,
I'm not terribly
interested in the
legal or legislative.
SPEAKER 3: Sure, nor
am I suggesting that.
SPEAKER 1: I'm looking
at technical solutions
where it's not possible
to get in the middle.
MALE SPEAKER 4: How
does this play out?
I mean the coffee
house is one example,
but the corporate environment
where the company wants
to step in and say, I'm going
to intercept this connection
to this unrelated site.
And otherwise, we have HSTS.
We never want this to happen.
SPEAKER 1: But as Mike said, if
the company owns the machine,
they insert something
in the trust store,
you sign the contract that
says I'm your employee.
I know you're going
to sniff my stuff.
And if you're
smart, you don't go
to your bank over
your company computer.
Or if you're in a prison
or if you're in a school--
they're often the
same sort of thing.
You have that relationship.
MALE SPEAKER 4: So we're really
going to the extreme of what's
allowed may not match
user expectations.
And I think users perhaps
are not expecting that, even
in enterprise, whether
or not they should.
SPEAKER 3: Let's get
back to the check box
though, for the airfare
thing or whatever where
you checked a box at some point.
And the problem is that
we have very little agency
to actually fight back on
that, where my lawyer talks
to the app's lawyer
and says, actually,
these terms I disagree with.
I don't want you
to sniff my stuff,
even though I work for you.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 4: All right,
we're running short on time.
But let's get a few
audience participants
on this most likely
last question.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, just
regarding Wi-Fi hotspots,
the captive portal situation--
even if they're not
trying to intercept
the traffic itself,
they are trying to
intercept the first session.
And currently, when
I'm on the road trying
to log onto a random
WiFi, I go to websites
that I know they are HTTP.
Otherwise, it just blocks.
So are there any plans
to standardize on that
and make that work?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, we've had
some background discussions
about this amongst a couple
different vendors to try
and improve.
Everyone's very keenly aware
of that, that that's a problem.
Getting the right
people in the room,
and especially because you
need the Wi-Fi networks,
you need the vendors creating
those captive portals,
you need the operating
system folks,
and sometimes,
the browser folks,
it's really hard to get
everybody in one place.
But we're working towards that.
It's not going to be any
time soon, unfortunately.
But yeah, it's a problem.
AUDIENCE: OK, so-- OK.
SPEAKER 1: Sorry.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Let's see.
And we had another
comment from the audience.
There we are.
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering, what can we
do to give better visibility
into what intermediaries
are installed?
So even if somebody has
exerted administrative control
over a device, it
doesn't mean that I
am necessarily aware of it.
I've heard rumors of
carriers installing things,
even my-- like, I may
not be aware that when
I pick up a device and I
install my corporate thing
that all my traffic is going
through a corporate proxy.
And I may be doing very
private things that I-- like,
maybe I want to opt out, right?
Maybe I want a different route.
How do we make that better?
SPEAKER 1: So there are
two parts to this I think.
One is, like we
were talking about,
improving the user experience
around the trust store.
So I can say, well, this CA,
trust it for these sites,
but not for arbitrary
other sites, for example.
And then there's been
some background chatter
for a long time now
about doing things
like end-to-end
signatures in HTTP
where you can sign
content for integrity
or have multiple layers of
encryption, things like that.
And there are a lot of people
really interested in that.
Getting the browser
guys interested in that
is a little harder so far.
But there's a lot
of interest there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I think part
of my question is maybe it's
more to the vendors,
to the browsers.
Because it seems like
sometimes-- and granted,
this is probably an
advanced use case.
But there are
cases where I would
like to opt out sometimes.
And this is not a
question about end-to-end,
has somebody
manipulated the content.
It's the fact that it was
seen by somebody else, right,
so you went through a proxy.
I want to opt out
sometimes, like maybe I
don't want specific
type of traffic
to be seen by my
corporate proxy.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Yeah, so with Chrome,
we don't have any
UI for proxies.
But I know that on
Android, if there
is a cert installed in
the trust store that
isn't one of the
pre-installed certs,
then there's a
persistent notification
up in the top bar that shows
you that your device is owned
by someone else, and
that it's completely
possible for your traffic
to be routed through someone
who can read it.
We don't have that on
Chrome OS, I believe.
And I don't think we
have it on desktop
either, because that's
really an OS level thing.
And it's something that
I think the operating
system needs to deal with.
But you're entirely correct.
The browsers can
and probably should
figure out ways of
making it clear to users
that their traffic
is not secure.
And maybe that's something
we do in the address bar.
Maybe we don't make
any sites green
if there's a cert installed.
I don't know.
I think there are--
SPEAKER 1: There are open
bugs for this in Chrome
and in Firefox.
And it's been quite
contentious from what I saw.
I mean-- and there
are two sides to it.
I don't really
understand the negatives
as well as I understand
the positives of doing
what you want to do there.
But, you know.
MALE SPEAKER 4: Well, I
think an interesting point
to wrap things up, a [? night ?]
in the security of usability,
some contention on
different sides.
Hopefully, we had some
good discussion here.
I think there's a lot
of good ideas around how
do we incentivize security so
people want to do it; how do we
balance the user experience
so they know what's happening;
how do we operate in a model
so what happens to users,
they're aware of and they think
that's correct or aware if it's
not.
But I really wanted
to thank everyone
on the panel, everyone in the
audience for good comments
and questions.
I think we'll leave
it there for today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE].